when you recognize this this new terrain
how you view 6 of the value or
responding to it well thank you Nicholas
yes it is a complex terrain of fast
changing to writing voice of America has
43 language services and I sometimes
tell people we have 43 market strategies
we really have no option but to be very
flexible and very adaptable and they
range from kind of our traditional model
since nineteen forty-two where perhaps
are trying to broadcast to it and what
we call a denied area the country that
doesn't where the government doesn't
want us reaching its public where our
government has decided we do wish to
reach them and we still do a good bit of
that I guess most notably we we
broadcast on satellite television in
Farsi to Iran and our most recent
numbers tell us that one in five Iranian
adults watches our television show at
least once a week so that's quite a lot
of impact in a place with government
doesn't want us and in fact faces the
compliment that a backwards backhanded
compliment of trying to jam our
broadcasts not terribly successfully so
we go all the way from that to whatever
whatever works in Latin America recently
we
going basically what I what I would call
an affiliate strategy and Washington
bureau strategy we've been going to
television and radio stations around
Latin America and saying you've got
anybody in Washington no we can help you
with that and we are now doing a lot of
reporting on Latin American television
and radio stations telling as condoms if
you will as as the Washington reporter
on the air in the context of a broadcast
that's being aired from Bogota or carta
Hannah or summer so it's it's all no one
model fits any one country and we're
trying all sorts of different things in
different places we are still using
shortwave radio where it works it's the
best way to reach people in North Korea
and it's an odd way and quite a few
other places in the world but it is fast
declining as the best way to reach
people in a number of other parts of the
world so we're on satellite television
raw FM radio we're on medium vibrate if
we're on the Internet we're on facebook
we're on skype we're on Twitter big time
we reach approximately 134 million
people we globally and we are it I think
probably the cheapest date and national
security that the United States has we
reach more people with something now
what are we recently that depends in
some cases it is it what you might call
a traditional news is this next set we
have charter which tells us that the
Congress passed this VOA will serve as a
consistently reliable in the heart of
the source of news VOA will be accurate
comprehensive and that is what we stand
for that's what we try to do good
old-fashioned journalistic values I
spent 32 years as a journalist and I'm
very comfortable with those values and I
think they need to be refreshed from
time to time it's exactly where we need
to be in terms of our news broadcast we
do all kinds of other things too one we
use whatever maybe there are we trying
to reach people on any platform that
human beings are using to communicate
with each other and these these little
videos that Jessica does are out on the
internet and they go viral in charge
she's had 14 million hits last year and
they also are on our daily to our
satellite TV broadcast China remember
you know reaching the audience doesn't
want to learn one of the things we do it
be ways teach English and what Jessica
specializes in is sort of young slang
young American slang and it it's very
popular in China also the Chinese don't
the Chinese censors don't censor it they
let it go through so we're we're on
everybody else's websites we've been
we've been passed around we don't get
filled out so it's a way of reaching the
audience with something that says the OA
on and says American English and is
aware if you will engage in the Chinese
public what we've got to offer being
relevant and you'll being passed along
your breaking into a loop for a closed
loop of Chinese young people and
providing something that's relevant to
them
part of their lives and I thing that's
tremendous it's tremendously that's
right maybe I should stop there around
the other Rajesh how does this perilous
rallies intravenously what do you
recognize this in my busy season sure
well the BBC is illustrating to enlarge
very wines I mean if I'd like just to
get a sense from all of you what do you
know of I say the ABCs you want is it so
here oh this is your turn man it's a
credible source of information and
that's trained a lot of other
broadcasters
okay so benchmark from another world
trust who's teaching English does the
World Service trust yeah that's the NGO
attachable BBC me new action their
treatment bc i should be made so anyone
else what what is being seen
cats
our second thing to do that
NPR and American media had a
relationship with the BBC that by
programming and they had a relationship
with you know they can use certain ports
here and they're terribly on on public
radio in this country you'll skip here a
chunk of BBC World Service has brought
in by the distributor of adjusting to
that particular station and EBS here as
well you'll see every day there's World
News America which is a news program
produced out of Washington DC that is
part of BBC world news but they
specifically in the American market and
in some media markets in the u.s. you
can actually have you see world uses a
channel when you're capable of sleeping
over DC we can't have don't around New
York on hotel or I was looking for last
night you can deny all the you support
groups just serve certain rights of
general by full disclosure by the way I
just finished the master day in Rome and
then it feeds so hope it's taught me
something the point I'm trying to get a
pistol in DC is hugely diverse and it
broadcasts in different formats to very
very wide array of audiences and the way
we fund it is also
very complicated as well Nick mentioned
the BBC World News which is out global
24-hour news channel is a commercial
operation or into the busy world service
near Olympia is our 24 hour radio news
network broadcast I think now 27
languages around that is at the moment
in time you government funded and the
leaves in the UK is something by the
licence fee which is amount of money i
think is 145 pound two hundred fifty
dollars that if you have a television
set you receive broadcasts do you have
to pay and that makes up the bulk the
BBC's income and then news content which
I am a tiny are you is funded
mainly by the licensee and as I will
provide use content based on an acting
traveler where an answer but I do by
user content for BBC outlets in the UK's
and it's interesting views I can provide
it for BBC World our commercial
operations over provided for the world
service as well I can be writing for our
website whether that's BBC your code of
UK which is the website available in the
UK or EU to com which is facing the US
and non UK markets and that's
advertising budget so it's a very
complex picture but in terms of
international broadcasting as a torrent
legacy we're not in any way shape or
form Tom wants to say quite opposite in
fact to be the one
think that because he had set himself
who sets you apart from other solitons
John with is that we're now editorial
independence from government is
enshrined in law something called the
Royal Charter which was the founding
document of the BBC's for nearly 10
years and that mandates the BBC to be
editorially depended from God but
healthy opportunities are affair the
reason that just because it's mandated
in law doesn't mean the government's
haven't attempted sure I've got a sack
and you have to keep you women this is
the same page for your way as well as
the historically governments of trying
to sway what's done I know what was the
situation in the manual for France my
capture EU you editorially independent
would you come under pressure to say
particular things um i would say that we
are you know i was working for today
private print publication why kenyans
country a years ago an IPF felt more
pressure then and now said basically
because it wasn't influential
weekly magazine that implants and sure
enough to be pressured but but I don't
think it's the city to play the same way
on the international scene as in place
on the National Domestic but just to
tell you with about France 24 hours UDF
I'm not going to ask you what you know
what France 24 design Fred I answer so
we are we are always being a young six
years in December we're small which my
followers to be many more nimble
hopefully so we on Twitter which is only
french english arabic and broadcast or
above all format way between for example
by a very strong presence on the
internet we have my facebook we have
almost 1 million france for a French
channel which is used for 24 functional
work so we are and we have a very strong
presence in what used to be nations
in which really West Africa obviously
that was not the reason why the China
was funded so it's kind of a touchy
subject for partitions cook the idea of
124 when it was from six years ago has
been in the process of being front of
the hunting for 10 or 15 years for that
and the idea was to do a CNN a deficit
of French French DNA not a vos en la
furia on set with French CNN because
French politicians used to travel around
during the hotel and be able to watch on
the CNN so the anywhere they were to go
private there was no proper irony that
could launch that so the state had had
to but I was really in terms of
presented at a time in terms of soft
soft power in terms of you try such
power meaning that I don't think engine
was at any point to really be how to
generate funding for ips spokesperson
for
government it was more sophisticated
than that and not very different from
BBC BBC Walker VOA was PG do you see
yourselves as being part of french open
to pose no no I don't see it I see
myself being a journalist I happen to be
French don't we can is that but now I
woke the French and the English Channel
but the i think is so the idea of having
a different voice that's what the
Chinese trying to convey is that because
we are our future way of seeing things
we're seeing the world way of
approaching the world etc be my other
different voice then we can find in the
BBC and CNN on suddenly on a broadcast
an ex parte and us so what we want you
to see some more cultural to go machine
I don't see adults my eyes there but as
moment to talk I don't see myself as a
game plan at all very promising French
diplomacy of course interferes with my
job might work but it would be the case
for any journalist any French and ne ne
and
even for private channel that's because
I'm French that when I default do a lot
of work with you at the UN covering the
UN for audience in DRC in Ivory Coast
and I've seen I've seen by those people
there listen to me as French and
therefore not so far from the front
government so that has to be taken into
context and company trying to my job but
if I was working for tf1 would happen
wishing to be private we've chatted
China in France podcasting in those
countries people who see me the same way
to enact that we gotta be the being
steady state founded on your teen state
funding is really not that relevant I
wanna show you put your life on should
in to bring the dumb points from the
matter we will talk minutes early made a
very interesting point that when you're
covering the story you want right now
it's more pressure which should be
absolutely
because you yeah yeah yeah Rhonda
obviously has relations with France
since 94 so whenever there is something
happening at un when I have to cover for
the bodies last few days DRC its
relationships with Rhonda I feel
pressure from my bosses in Paris it's
never taken that way but that we need to
do the right thing even for order for
any other subject because we are going
to be looked at work when we looked at
more closely and on anything else
because the Wonder government is sweaty
at French government didn't tell me we
were working on this question and
because we are seeing received at the
government so the only way for us to
react to that is to do a job even try to
go drop even more seriously so the only
question illusion in that is the way I
was right that's what I was right it's a
pressure to be more professional and
appear more possible avoiding our
tummies and I think there's a lick
there's a link there between the BBC and
precious path we are as people in this
room have said PVC is known formed let's
easy ality talent delivery of care and
binds means that's what many people say
or the DVR element and I think the fact
that we do that reflects the values of
British democracy that can withstand
previously the beautiful values that the
BBC's editorial independence and the way
we defend this independence are ones or
free expression free speech plurality
you debate and I think in terms of what
the British government gets out of that
British government realizes that by
holding on and cherishing our
independence from government which
government gets on camera we generate
some benefit but this is part of the art
irony of international broadcasting is
that it can be over certainly the
Western approach international
broadcasting is that it generates more
soft power the less the government
actually intends to use it its own power
and the closer the eldest broadcasting
the less
people asking completely less credible
the broadcasting less credible we are
the national broadcast we're not the
sexual custom this is very informative
oh the another problem that I see BBC is
the one isn't it the BBC has got some
data on this which they haven't
necessarily quick to share and that's
when they talk to people around the
world about do you like the BBC people
say yes I respectfully we see beauty
secret sauce use a millisecond where is
the BBC come from evil aren't
necessarily shoring and they're not sure
what could be worth of whether it's
somewhere in the West is it written is
in America they may think of it
sometimes connected to their leaders
broadcast in the language wing so the
BBC is starting to operate almost as an
international answer in turn right
almost like an NGO that happens to be
broadcasting except dr. no no no no
no but then your line contain Montana
usually but so but if you can be cleaned
go out of the same operating
international breast waste waste time
buzzer when the brand becomes
dissociated from Britain when people
don't see the Union Jack on the ground
you can be serving British interests
without necessarily other as I say it's
in Britain
the world care about climate change or
will be have to refer sympathy for
pluralism resistance to radicalization
those are good things crib but is not
necessarily putting the Union Jack on
things and is that something that you're
aware of or a disconnect between Britain
and in DC I mean we always know that
wizard which forecasts inflation that's
today so it was a reminder in the day
where operation again for it
increasingly we are broadcasting in
different languages on multiple
platforms as you know where we're going
whether your audience it so well so
close a little short wave language
services but it's opened up fmz from
those countries for the television
services like for example do you see
world news now it's Persian yeah Big Z
Arabic we have BBC Swahili you see in da
living for startled is done coming
online there are several languages i
think i recently by golly we have taken
ten different images so we try to be
more things to all people but always
with that standard quality this is the
BBC branded awesome so you know
created trust what I wanted to ask David
is how what is your sense of how your
relationship with your audience is
changing as is do you recognize this
business of the transition from the
audience who would be the tide consumer
like a person who's got the plumbing
coming into their house to give up
what's your experience endless changing
well how do you relate to give you an
example something about living in Russia
no not long after Putin came in he took
us off a whole series of mostly radio
with some television affiliates that we
have Russia and they had sort of
resentful now what we do so we have very
much digital strategy one of the things
we've done is the last year since I've
been director to start the program for
what release which we share and it is
the audience that decides what it shows
about and the audience are often part of
the show they decide by SMS and Twitter
and so forth what they like the subjects
to be covered tomorrow show and we
frequently have members of the audience
on skype on the telephone participating
in discussions with the experts they
said they wanted us no deficit grateful
so yeah so it's you don't have it's
fairly new show you don't have her
but it's starting to get a lot of
feedback from the audience it seems to
be what young russians water wash and
this is a this is shows on the Internet
and that's mostly where everybody's but
we also put it up on a satellite
so there's an example on an earlier
point you mentioned about about bulletin
thing is just one act oh you know you're
right that our funders some of our
funders don't really understand what we
are and would like us to be more
propaganda boys and i can remember
saying to you know somebody who out
whose opinion I value y know supports
our budget you know I could follow it
all that but I was found myself saying
to him congressman now you know the best
answer to propaganda isn't more from yet
it's truth we're the truth business and
it's in our charters in the law if you
want to change it you have to change law
by the way it works people would much
rather be told what the hell's going on
and then respect them to let them decide
what they won't think about that that's
what the kind of narrow ilysm I wanted
to do was a commercial broadcaster I'm
very proud that that's what I think
voice America like BBC impossible also
trying to but i think this business of
power in the audience is very
scene was doing a strand of lunch times
in BBC to Africa quarter gram per day
but if you're asking Africans to suggest
what they wanted to talk about and the
amazing thing was the new subjects are
being generated by the audience that
nothi a broadcasting house with people
let's do a show a suicide nigeria were
texting ends and we really want to talk
about suicide the audience took british
broadcasting all sorts of new places
terrific proofing model and it ensures
that you're going to be relevant to your
audience if you're actually asking them
what do you want us to talk about but I
think that's the audience is fragmented
and they're available they are consist
and they consume be here different web
or go after you necessarily have to be
asking your audience what do you want
Fox you want that too late okay what
Africa you're saying there's there's
well necklace which is a World Service
radio program as well that means that
much to television program as well
interactivity of you called it again but
it's interactivity for us write it up
you have to be responsive to your
audience not only in terms of where they
are consumed you output we're doing that
all over yes we have something we call
France 24 hours the program were
basically but its mother a gradualist
and it's gravy germany so the air is try
to find way to use for sourcing that's
something with me and it works very well
in Africa a lot of places where conflict
or even just do you work very well
during our spring and that whatever
which channel for us people type for
bragging and the lonely programming
dialog between the journalists and other
people trying to say is it's each
program TV which also internet it's a
constant so you can you can have a
problem when you actually have people
calling from the sky requesting
everybody's goal is to
so we don't call them before we have
tried to check that to a question that
comes up think about it national focus
is a question competition and all of us
each of you who you see as your
competition my time from it when I'm
talking about future for 24 on the what
I see it gone to for us it when I see
the chinese coming up twitter with the
end so so it's a political scene in
France our patient is clearly all the
other all the powers of the world which
usually watch video
for us but trying to try to set foot in
those areas of the world I used to be
French so you guys you say that's how
the way I see myself as from the France
24 season service protecting the front
of me it's more icons other politicians
on people phoning us that might see us
that way and then it's not the way I
think Jordan is working for the charity
themselves which I mean the petition is
the bdc4s keys sometime so that's
interesting to have two different to the
or to add my attention someone
competitive the journalism well that's
one of the reasons can be too well
that's why I'm you know that's what I'm
the medium is funny to bottom yeah Roger
to you what I you also give me is
representative of the BBC orsa it is a
correspondent it's every other column
often grow in terms of bc i mean we know
we have strong brand we are blessed that
we have big audiences you trust but we
also know that there is increasing and
increasingly crowded marketplace
broadcasters increasingly crowded
marketplace for ideas having studied a
master Fung closing program the last
year I can tell you that we face what's
called a paradox of Plenty which is that
in the list increasingly crowded long
place variety is what is shortened by
his attention and the sources that are
going to get your attention of the ones
that have credibility so we are
competing against all these other voices
out there we're also competing against
ourselves just to make sure that we
every day go out and do as well as we
can in order to maintain our brand and
make you stronger cellular 43 market
support through strategy
I you know obviously we're accomplishing
CCTV in xinhua there is estimates say
that trying to spend eight billion
dollars in the next couple of years to
expand in national radio television
broadcast a two-sided soft power support
during our budget the total budget of us
international broadcasting which is five
companies be away the largest are
casting board covers so we can't match
the kinds of money that China wants to
spend RT russia today spending a lot of
money now that spanish broadcasts you
know it depends on which market you're
talking about in in western Pakistan in
the tribal areas I'm competing with the
Taliban radio and wish which is scarless
and lies and very very very sad stuff
going on there air we tell the truth and
we're
reached that part of the world with
serious effective broadcasting one of
our journalists was killed in January
for doing so in in other places there
are places where just about you and me
in northern Mali right now they've
closed down the Islamist rebels have
closed down all the radio stations we've
found a creative way to get short audio
newscasts every two or three times a day
three minutes on people's cell phones
and because the Islamists also have cell
phones and don't want to close that down
we've still got an avenue to reach
people and it's just as far as I know
just about the only way you might have
something like this I don't know about
you but very few people are able to know
what's going in northern Mali what's
really going on the rest of the world
aren't that many ratios I guess shortly
is still still a good way but these
little letters preso cell phone things
are very effectively thing so in some
places are competitor to steer in
ignorance yeah that's that's that's a
good onset of air diggers but some of
your predecessors would never given that
on situations that the tradition of the
airway has seen itself this was
competing with BBC
in a friendly kind of way I mean I'm
December I'm going to Berlin meeting of
the DG 5 the directors general 51
western broadcasters in p.m. we refresh
we break bread together we may have a
different you know we can we talk it we
taught us I know if there's something
for me this is very strong in place and
we're thinking where we have resources
about them a lot more less likely what
your summer but am i fighting this this
is actually quite an important approach
and but because there's so little is a
comparatively little Western board
asking to go round right I think the
more we can get together and decide well
when you focus on them our focus on
Indonesia or you know there are two to
divide up a man rather than proceeding
in an underwater native way or an
unnecessary competitive very encouraging
I wanted to ask each of you you have a
sense of how international broadcasting
is developing if there was one thing
that you could change about set up
working what would probably be really
spoke Emmanuel if you could change one
thing about the setup or the scope or
would you can
what language is or what would you I
think I would like to have the channel
as you mean where it is which is maybe
not necessarily because we are this
product of niche that we were talking
about that it should also apply to us in
something you know we're strong in West
Africa that's a great thing and too
often people talk about a channel they
see that as we we don't want be channel
just perfect but that is most of this
country we are some of those countries
we are the only credible news channel 4
news channel how they're so it's
breaking really we have we have to be
there more often sometimes have to
struggle to pitch stories that are
targeted to an African audience
exclusively because we are we have only
one program for everybody of the champ
at french alan Wilson program as we seen
everywhere what
I so maybe develop in a niche NE we do
ask me what we r who we r who we r
talking and letting the strong in those
countries people speak French that's
great friends that's great that's the
language that still eager to vote sticky
to have news they're able to learn in
that conflict so we should not be a
shame of that control maybe more in
focusing on that more and also in terms
of the object of the niche medelln we
are in some cable works I one video
sequence on board in English and the
idea is I'm not sure it's always concede
that way right by my channel with that
the target is we need a fence news
junkie people by trusting in the war
news and we want to have a different
perspective on on the news and in that
sense when internationals channel in the
sunset you know you say that reducing
broadcast to an international audience
it's also we are also in the nations
challenge in the sense that bitch so
manly but international news and other
people in this country air when you know
i gotchu equality you should you tell me
it's going to the have you that can see
on the US networks sample piece that
remain reason
but that's also something we should be
should welcome all these youth Chinese
people who are just interested in
different views different friends a baby
not only serving the news junkies but
also bringing would you want to be a
gateway drug trafficking better for you
you want to encourage more people to be
news junkies rather than the very
parochial use consumption that you
sometimes America tends to fall into
Roger what would you change to things
like the BBC because it has so many
different services and outlets does vast
number of stories I love it we didn't
even talk secondly we go to changing
perceptions unlike in believe news dirty
is up to what you were saying we reach
particular audiences I mean you in this
room are not typical audiences some of
us you might be but you know you are
interested in international affairs you
interested Carlos you're interested in
news and we spent 12 evening talking
listing
Pal Singh is questioning me most people
probably watching the voice I'd really
like it if those people would be more
interesting because there's so much
going on that it's so important that I
hope well obviously I'd like to have
more money and I'm gonna make the pitch
to the hole in halls of Congress is so
corny but honestly I think we are a
really inexpensive way to reach awful
lot of people and with a message that an
American message and it may be he said
what simple newscast that attempts to
the objective in ways that may be
literally they don't care that much or
it might be some program in about the
United States and explaining American
values some of our largest audience
growth in at BOA has occurred when when
there was bad news in the united states
that would grade was greater the away
why as we told the story warts and all
and people weren't priced his businesses
been the sound of storage what are they
what about you know it was a good civics
lesson that we were able to get it how
the United States recognizes its own
problems and deals with them corrects me
how we have pretty good correction
mechanisms daughter or society so what
would I like what more funds I am trying
to broaden the definition of New Boyz
and the bread definition of what we do
we talked about the music the jazz the
project essentially
we have a structure we have such rich
musical traditions in the United States
I'm trying to bring some new tenants the
new television music shows radio shows
back to do and can enrich and that what
we offer we're doing some partnerships
with for example we have one with
National Geographic half hour show every
week but basically they have a lecture
series Washington interesting explorers
dynamic people scientists and we do
something jointly with that so I'm
trying to broaden hydration what it is
we offer the world on voice are now if I
could often if I could not gonna love
this if there were if I hadn't won power
to change a piece of legislation in the
United States is there any legislation
with life change in the front row here's
Lynn wild good she could give you a very
precise list but I'll be concisely to
say that we first of all there's some
people Smith on back this is where our I
didn't want to set at IHS kind of out of
his facebook how date it when it was
started was a law is a law among many
other things someone who might good
quite still tappable one of the things
that says is the oal she'll talk
in the United States well I mean the law
is an ass i'm sorry but you've got any
one of our internet sites and listen to
any one of our broadcasts just by
clicking on it now and there's nothing i
can do to stop you even though the
technically there may be of audits I
mean it's it the technology has overcome
this law but now what we like is just a
quiet little amendment that will allow
us to do the following when a minnesota
public radio calls us success got a lot
of somali refugees up here they're cold
and they miss your somali broadcast
which seventy-three percent of Somalis
listen to in Somali could we please have
it sorry no you know and that's a pity
because it would no extra cost to anyone
to be serving that Somali
but instead they care like I watch it
they get to listen to the most extreme
person in that community almost
certainly won't be sympathetic united
states like orogenic obama's and this is
this is serious especially when you look
at the ability of the youth of the BBC
to move freely between domestic and
international and even in the English
language BBC has the ability to offer
valuable international perspective to
America to NVR the other things you have
enrollment with the VA way as you said
earlier you have to now start to think
about language groups without national
borders there are 800,000 Farsi speakers
of the state of California alone is is
there Farsi is an international global
language it's all over the place and we
have to think about it that way so so I
think the law is out of date I'm not
asking nor what I advocate that the u.s.
government spend money for us to
broadcast the US but just to make our
products to knock down the available and
fundus somebody is in California up
across the Metro there are slowing down
we have this issue of domestic
international when we were funny he said
there was a publishing private a big
private this was actually a real one
basically the private companies got
about fifty percent of the new home
working on it 24 and then running in a
change but it was important for the
politicians to be able to say that was
published by the internet and there was
no I was going to be able to have some
private money didn't work out well so
the few years was he get more perfect
but but the next change of heart
speaking that those private companies
obtained that france24 can be broadcast
in France especially on the
the digital terrestrial zero which is
huge transfers within the US or okay and
actually so it was a big weakness for
hospice and all of us to have domestic
audience especially those people who are
just interested in international dians
hoop interested in what we do when the
other is frenchy news channel 2 and
that's also weakness for channel as go
try to get more money puts it back
nobody watches that because they don't
know it's starting to change we are one
more present under on domestic networks
and also answer when interesting thing
in Denali channel he can last frame
became for few weeks it was the most
view news channel in the country yeah
China but there was an omen
the best tools is this guy who hosted
his future you know I was shot by the
police at the end so it was like dr days
and days and that that even was followed
closely by and which was seen as
something you know we were not sure
about that cause a lot of talk back no
terrorism they don't watch the news in
French so then but my daddy was much
better for then watch the new france 24
in our rather than china so that's also
some unhappier has become since then one
of the you know risen forefront when it
ought to be this is this race is one of
the one of the things in this is the
reason for the Smith contact and it's
come to be explained as almost like
exactly like derivative Posse Comitatus
this principle of the US Army coming to
boy in the US in the same way American
propaganda that's meant for overseas
audiences muscle peepers must be
receivable at home because otherwise the
ruling party would have an unfair
advantage in swinging American elections
and the American people can't be exposed
propaganda that was that was the
argument whether in the nineteen
60s and 70s when they began to debating
the changing the stereotype but as
everybody saturday so i am going to the
BBG provides a fire wall there they
appoint me and not appointed by the
president hoist America doesn't work we
are not the voice of the president of
the present current present with the
voice of America we're a broadcaster
what I was going to say is that the real
muscle divided the Smith Montague was
the work was a poor American broadcast
yes that's right but particularly if you
don't pan news agencies particularly
associated press who really knows a
young very close I know my old employers
at ABC News didn't want ever change
either they didn't want so this is but
it's difficult to see how that would
apply to foreign languages as long as an
ABC or CBS providing services in Somali
maybe if they were this wouldn't be this
will be an issue they'll CNN it to the
body
turn to channel I don't know what the
reasons are but it used to be the world
services available it was super bra
clasp as a filler I have a 90-minute
yeah so teenager that's what I'm 1980
world news I'm just one of those I stuck
it out my children yeah and gives the
world news intelligent channel does
civil Caspian beauty news challenges our
domestic television overnight I think
that one of the advantages but not
having the Smith Mont restraint has
given to Britain is there's tremendous
domestic awareness within the UK about
what we see is what it does
internationally and ordinary British
heard of the BBC World Service a level
of prime inning and Smith mum taxes or
prevented Americans from knowing that's
one of the reasons i like to see it
Amanda not seeking to me
would like to have a few more Americans
understand this very good use of their
tax dollars and how it helps the world
tops United States because without it
you get is international broadcast on
the sku so one corner us international
broadcasting has been immensely local
constituency us grow accustomed to Cuba
is artificially sustained political
reasons by a constituency and knowing is
outraged when parts of boa closed down
or their ways funding is carved seems it
seems very